josh is with us in Logan West Virginia
hi Josh how are you good Dave how's it
going better than I deserve what's up
I'm calling to ask you a couple
questions I've got a debt right now
various things medical bills college
costs and some fines in legal fees from
driving on a suspended license and I
want to know whether we would be better
for me to consolidate this debt or file
bankruptcy also I have a ten thousand
dollar civil suit pending which I fully
expect I'm going to have to pay
restitution on so that'll bump it up
from thirteen to twenty three thousand
why do I think this has something to do
with the suspended license you're very
correct if you want to go more into
detail it's probably a history of drug
use but I'll share with you that I've
been clean two years and one month good
for you congratulations that's all so
thanks how'd you get a clue you know I
got tired of sitting in jails and I got
out and I said I'm not going to live
like that anymore
that's cool what kind of drugs were you
doing prescriptions non prescriptions
you name it I took it okay and so you
got it - you got duis on that they
jerked your license and then there was a
car wreck I guess yeah okay all right
and so yeah you're going to lose the
suit now how much of the how much debt
do you have total right now it is
approximately 13,000 okay that's good
news and how much of that is student
loans there are no loans I've paid off
all my loans but the college side of it
is unpaid college costs I owe one
University one thousand three hundred
and forty four dollars for attending but
never paying yes okay I got you
oh and another one I owe about three
thousand okay and how much are the fines
Shh let's look 3000-4000 okay and the
$10,000 lawsuit is for a damaged
automobile yes and and you're going to
lose that you're going to lose that
lawsuit because you did it
right in the subrogation suit the
insurance company is suing me right
but that's not going to be restitution
because they have they tied that to a
criminal charge yes and in the criminal
court I was ordered to pay no
restitution okay so it's not restitution
it's civil then it's not correct yes if
you don't pay restitution in a criminal
thing you go back to jail you got that
right right I've paid all mine so the
civil suit does not put you in jeopardy
of that it's not restitution in a
criminal sense it is it is it is money
you owe because you did tear up the car
there's not question about that but
you're not denying that but what I'm
trying to do is make sure I'm not giving
you advice that has to do with jail time
okay right so so really you got four
thousand dollars in fines you got a
lawsuit hanging out there thirteen
thousand dollars in debt total I'm still
missing maybe one large debt is there
something else I'm missing how'd you get
what was the other ones medical there
are some medical bills
let's see medical is that women does the
thirteen thousand include the lawsuit is
that what you're talking about
no if if the lawsuit were added in it
would be twenty three thousand okay all
right all right are you working not
right now I just had a job interview so
if you could wish me good luck on that
one more than that I'll pray for you
that's cool all right making Meaghan
what kind of money nothing okay just get
the song away [ __ ] started again how old
are you 25 good good
okay well the bad news is you've been
through a bunch of crap the good news is
you recognized it you put it in a
rearview mirror and you did it young
enough that it doesn't shape your whole
life it's just one of those you're just
going to have some scars from you know
from bumping into stuff right from
touching a hot stove all the time yeah
and so you know you got it you got a
really bright future if you keep
yourself clean and so I'm excited for
you I'm proud of you you're doing good
stuff here this is good so the question
is do you file bankruptcy
$13,000 or $23,000 if it comes up I put
bankruptcy in the same category as
divorce and by that I mean I some people
have to do it sometimes sometimes
there's a mess sometimes there's people
you can't get it you just doesn't work
right
it's horrible there's all kinds of bad
things that happen but you want to do
everything you can to avoid it right and
so in this situation to start with right
now you don't have any money and you
don't have a job and so nobody can get
anything from you today anyway so you're
not going to file bankruptcy today under
any circumstances let's say you land a
job and one of these people came after
you and sued you and start taking your
income and they might force you into a
bankruptcy at that point because you
might have to do that just to eat right
you need to know that the $4,000 and
fines are not going away they're not
going to be bankrupt able right that's
going to still be there so and you also
need to know that the $10,000 lawsuit
from the other guys insurance company
not the other guy right is going to that
they will settle that with you for
probably three grand if you wrote them a
check okay you think yeah I do because
let's put their shoes on for a minute
what do they think it let's say you were
on the other side of the desk from you
um you don't look real collectible it's
not like I'm looking across the desk at
a millionaire and I'm going dude dude
I'm gonna just tap on his accounts I got
down here that's unemployed his licenses
suspended he's been sitting in jail he's
been dry a few months and a few years
now but I mean you know you I'm hopeful
for you but if I'm on the other side of
this from a legal perspective saying it
can I collect a debt from this guy on
average you know we and it's to your
advantage by the way you don't look real
appealing okay that that's not the
insult you that's to your benefit you
see what I'm saying yeah okay so that's
a good news so we use that and we say
hey guys you know we're going to save up
$3,000 and offer that to you to settle
that in full and then you begin to work
your way through these other debts one
at a time are any of them chasing you
aggressively today what with collection
yes sir
yeah practically all of them they're
just calling you or what letters call
anybody seems you know okay all right so
so so right now it's just emotional
pressure not legal pressure except for
the insurance suit yeah yeah but even
that they haven't won yet and so there's
anything with it yet right so uh and you
don't even deny that you owe that right
well I mean I have counsel that's
working with them okay on that well
counsel can help you settle it too so
here's the thing if I mean have you got
your license back no I I have so many
fine you got to get the fines to get the
license yeah okay well first goal is get
that license back and what I'm gonna do
is pick up every odd job I can
Construction cutting grass anything
we're somebody swing by and pick you up
and put you on the put you out there
doing something and just go crazy and
get those fines knocked out and then get
you back in the driver's seat we can
deliver pizzas and do some other stuff
and if you can make thirty thousand
bucks a year and live on nothing you can
clean this up really really fast a
little bit at a time and I'll help you I
want to be part of your healing hold on
I'm going to have Kelly pick up we're
going to put you in Financial Peace
University teach you how to handle money
you're not bankrupt you just need a job
in a new life
you